[Music]
don't wait don't
wait for
[Music]
so no gu you no no none of those pins
has to be a real pin
course everything count so all whatever
CH style is it's part of it
[Music]
did you ask not to be you just not okay
don't stop them and get the gr grab yes
don't
[Music]
stop Sean you can
jump everything counts
then again those pins don't count
he he doesn't go up you don't go up you
don't go up
[Music]
okay so
what and this this Isa so I don't do
uh okay I'm doing so you want to do
[Music]
that
want like this and
snap you're going to do whatever
technique you got to follow the
energy don't don't lean
back I'm here
see you understand otherwise he's going
down okay
[Music]
off line
on Don't Stop
The don't stop
[Music]
get your feet on the
ground on the ground switch rotate
can't do that one can't do the FR from
the back
the he keeps turning on you it's fine
okay why is he turning down cuz I'm not
I'm not do you see him turning yes okay
so why is he turning
oh I'm not pinning his base
down well start it's very simple why is
it turn because he can turn okay and so
now what what's contributing to his
ability to
turn the fact that he still has his full
base yeah what okay what's contributing
to his full
base
um well his center of gravity is still
inside his base of
support yes I know
okay look stay there look do you see
that hey R look at his posture do you
see do you see that difference go back
where you were do you see so he he's he
already is disengaging okay so just
address the disengagement okay then find
his Center where wherever you need to
okay cuz it's not right
can right but I want it does he can't be
wrong on this
okay what did I
do what' I
do what' I do did I did I get a center
did he fall like a ton of bricks did he
turn no why he you kept his grip well
he'll know what was different on that
you entered yeah you knocked my face I
took his legs out heting you get it he's
like I actually fell for real do
you see that oh you do the other one you
do the other ones and he'll turn on you
you see he he'll turn he'll turn on you
CU he'll he'll disengage okay that's
part of the
technique again you can
see falling like a brick okay got it yes
what counts onto you
okay you have to find his
center now I not K him I didn't go my
fastest but I didn't let him turn on me
okay it's still not fun but I didn't
kill
him you going way faster than
me you see so you're you're trying to
get his Center by in the
inertia that's going to be dangerous
okay and he's just going to disengage
more and get out more cuz we're still
not at attack inera just find the center
of this
inersia okay so Virginia what would that
mistake be what's he doing pushing
what's he doing what's that called
what's he trying to do he's doing an
IO we don't do IO in in Gazo
it's got to lower the head so you get
the hip over the head angle that's all
you got to do at this speed you just got
to go a little lower okay
don't stop
him you can't pick and don't pick and
choose feel the energy
don't
stop so let's say I'm doing something
like
that it doesn't
work it'll work
it work I'm not saying do it but you get
into problems only when you go what was
I thinking do you see that just feel the
energy feel the
energy
anything is going to work
let's say he comes around he doesn't
fall you just feel the energy keep him
go just keep it let him
push feel
it energy
moving not my thing but at least we're
not stopping okay and we're not picking
okay TR
another
CH let's
go that's
it was good you had to adjust you had to
adjust to find the center is
fine
yes this is better training
[Music]
do technique not a not exercise
you got to know the
techniques or follow the
energy there's only four chances then
you go
[Music]
cross this is an exercise
it's a very awkward move you notice we
don't really do
that you know talking
you know what I'm talking I don't really
do
[Music]
that heps
around sometimes when I do do that move
I come down and the
leg get out of there careful on that if
you would just be a little
more especially at this at this speed
this speed is the speed okay so you go
and you do that move
yeah this is what happens I don't do
anything he has to do something okay you
understand I don't feel I don't feel
like this I don't feel like
that I just I'm just doing this he does
whatever he cut my Center
okay got it so
[Music]
try it
again I learn with the inertia I got I
don't do exercises I don't do poou
pins that's what we're so far that's
what we're
going have to find a center we stay slow
the inertia is what we have that's all
we have okay go
I
[Music]
this are all momentum throw
on get it B
[Music]
so I don't do this technique like that
pay
attention I don't do these
you want to do something like that you
got to get the
leg you want to do other don't know here
look P the
elbows not here not
here get something get his
body get something on him
okay something on him
find the
center I don't have it but I'm going to
okay got
it okay try it again they're falling is
not the goal it's how I make him fall
okay
it's
[Music]
see that's where ran and Tristan would
have just laid on their stomach or went
to their knees not did a forward rooll
it's just a momentum thing that's all
she's doing okay come on
how how much inertia is coming in right
right I would come in pretty freaking I
think you has the perfect speed okay I I
I like how Taylor and AD are
training okay
hey you got to get the yield in there
you're very small
who you see doesn't happen in real life
yes you have to you have to get this
part okay so you're here right then you
go this way
into it that's
it okay try it
again and I don't what is that that's
like the beginning of Techni not the end
of a
technique okay and that's not the angle
for it
even okay that that angle is the you if
you if you're doing that one right if
you're if you're going to do the ten con
this has to go okay and he gets up cool
and you work it again here's the
he otherwise you can
here there's the
he you understand but you don't do this
this is not a
technique okay okay come on you got to
figure out what is gu what is it come on
let's go ch ch for people
okay so stop so talk about that one so
you let your grip
go so her Center did not get as
connected so he attacked the base do you
see that don't want your base attacked
don't let go of the grip okay got do you
see how that works but it's his job to
get the control of the person that's
their line of gravity center of gravity
base of support okay
try personally I would I would let go
cuz like please don't sweep Me All Night
Long
okay that's the one doesn't work that's
the
same this this this one is the la la one
you see and and uh let's see I'll figure
it out I got to figure and
this is the la la one to don't work in
real life okay so the guy turns on you
right you have to come to something
else got it oh it turns on you right
okay cool that's where you
grab you understand or he turns on
you right B come back
around that's a counter it should feel
like coun it shouldn't feel like
open you need control center so he
doesn't turn on
better
[Music]
make sure you lower one side of the a
Thea is slower you have to lower it then
you can go over
same same rule there the inertia is low
you have to lower it so you can go over
it it should be something you should
[Music]
feel we're on hand
not come
on hey so you acting like his Center's
going to go up you understand but you're
taking his Center down you're taking his
head
down taking his head down do you
understand what I mean by
that yes you keep you keep expecting his
Center to go you keep expecting him to
be in this position do you see that but
you're going like this why would he be
in that position you see then you turn
him and that's how you get
here this hand goes this way you see
that difference and then he goes past
you get control here then this hand
comes out but he
but he's going to do what to you he's
going tobly he's probably let go see pay
attention see see all that keep your
grip keep your grip look how much I get
okay loosen your
grip okay and then you're taking his
head down turning
him make sense okay so you just work
with that he turns on you cool it is
right here
you understand you want to do that
though probably not we probably fix him
after that so all I'm doing go
here is
okay come
on stck in
PN you have the wrong pattern we can't
notice
it just feel the
energy so see how he crunched you see
how he crunched you should felt that he
he regained his
Center you have to do something else not
a technique what's the energy I need to
get and striking is not it that's what
all the I do I just
[Music]
face you don't take Where You Are
don't don't pick don't don't unpick
either all right
I I what I need and
that's don't any
[Music]
I don't go oh I just did that one let me
do something else okay that's as strong
as picking don't unpick either okay just
be in the movement feel the energy feel
the ground Vector follow l b use your in
or and out
spirals okay I have to feel their Center
that's what's being okay
try you might do the whole four rep
every
time for
[Music]
so if if
my could you feel like she's not in the
right place could you feel that like
it's just a there's the only way I can
be in the wrong place is I'm not in the
moment well where am I then I'm in the
tech I'm in the selection of the
technique it's the only way you're
trying to you're trying to do your
Technique and you're
like that this foot here does not go
with the head do you see that so if if I
use that foot then that foot has to do
something
else do you understand so but if you if
you are over here and you're like oh I
want the head and that is where you're
going to
be okay so the signs of
reaching reaching pulling this I'm
taking the technique I'm not feeling the
energy okay TI enery don't take the
technique
let's go
to what
[Music]
don't that was
bad wasn't in there for E so let me go
okay that was better only we did a
momentum throw at the end yes
[Music]
okay should be should be effort because
your is so low right you understand and
then I'm just
working with what what you're giving me
okay that's all I'm do
you probably can't tell that uh they
can't very trying
because it's all gradual
gradual
gradual there's no big
moments this kind of stuff it's
gradual you see so this is just my hand
W okay
not
you that
it's your turn it's your
turn I know I did show that stuff but I
didn't say not my
thing not to spin around
right there in with the right
arm that's
and look how
ight to you you see that Virginia you
get that okay so now you're
like why just take it Gra ually
gradually you say HD it gradually okay
so you're like I just that was it that's
a little more you see then I go here you
see you get get what I'm doing and then
I was like oh that's that's going to be
more muscle
okay take the base do you understand as
opposed to like forward shoving
everything pulling everything
try try to find like muscle muscle
muscle okay I go this way you
see
this okay
you're trying to find where where is the
technique if it's there then it's
efficient and it's gradual it's not all
at once with abrupt changes in Direction
okay try it
again like on the shoulder that's where
you
felt and that's what you don't want to
do
right there you can I could see you
trying to use Muscle there just stop
it's telling you don't keep going there
it's telling you do something else
[Music]
you're coming a lot of this stuff you
got this Techni here
so his head's going down
cool it's not the same because the
shoulder joint is not the same the
shoulder joint on that forward one goes
this way you see that the shoulder joint
doesn't go that way on the back you get
it understand
okay his head is down work with his head
going down his head is down you're going
to the front inward kazushi if his head
is up you're going on the back outward
kazushi okay don't don't take the don't
pick a technique CU you might pick one
head down them and try to make them go
into the back outward or back inward
that's not that's that's fighting his
energy okay try it again right
okay so now just minute gu
[Music]
right see how you reach up so high hi
good trying to Crunch him
down so let's say lean
backwards you see that and you're like
how do I he's too tall for me so you
want more angle down you see that your
solution is this one some variation of
that
okay so you kind just move him move
him you get that you understand okay
you're like oh we stopped moving okay
cool you
see then end the technique right or that
time where go ahead get up and you're
like here and you turn towards you down
okay
cool in the technique okay
okay try it
again is gu
so just move out of the way be ready to
stomp him in the
face try to find that effortless hand
weight alone two two o will do
so his head is going down but you keep
wanting to bring him back up
you know there there's a technique like
that is so Dam
effective just go
here you just go here and you just slam
his head on the
street okay you're like rejecting it
with some
weird bad I te
this put your hands on his head you're
taller than him you see that it's not
the same problem as Virginia you just
you have it don't don't reject it to do
some weird thing where you're violating
that keto okay try it
again I'm not say do it now but you get
it it's like just accept the energy is
the problem he
that would be reaching for
that's very
good start turn right
then
lower energy
two ight right yes
[Music]
and you come in
you you're out here have to come in and
then just do it control so that you
don't kill her
okay all right
[Music]
the
I didn't see I just saw in the did it
work I still yeah you got you got to get
in your leg your leg has to pass the
Apex can't can't be here
okay you have to be
close Okay four more each
[Music]
so when when you have those arms
get so inad of coming here now I don't
have you see that you do the other one
El rather than taking the near elbow
take that and the
elbow then again don't kill her it's a
tough again if you're following where's
her Center you would you should have
felt the slack in the arm on near arm
and that's not where you touch okay you
have her Center you let go of it that
should felt weird to okay I don't have
the center here that's where I let go
okay again follow the feeling okay
it's too
tall and always don't stand behind the
cape when you're bull
fighting you guys understand that okay
Cape goes one way you go the other way
okay thank